Okay, is it okay for a cancer patient to take
El glutamine for a short period of time?
This person is referring to what I talk about quite frequently that a cancer patient
should not be on glutamine supplementation because glutamine is one of the amino acids that
can be a direct fuel source for cancer.
However, let's say you're in a fairly good state of remission but you have major
gut issues and you want to heal the gut.
Can you go on a glutamine supplement for a short period of time?
My answer is yes, you can.
I would say a lower dose glutamine supplement.
Now there are some glutamine, so
El glutamine is a supplement that is used to help heal the gut.
Why is it used to help heal the gut?
Because glutamine helps stimulate cell reproduction.
Quite readily, let's stimulate cell reproduction.
Well, why would I even want to do that for the five cancer?
Well, if your cancer is in remission and it's not a intestinal cancer, let's say it's breast cancer.
But you know, your Evan remission, I do really well.
Now I got to heal my gut.
I'm having major gut problems.
I say it's okay to take glutamine for a short period of time.
What do I mean maybe for a month or maybe two months?
And not take high dose glutamine because there are glutamine supplements that are four,
five grams of glutamine.
I think that's way too much.
I think taking less than a gram of glutamine would be your best way to do it.
We have a product called Clear GI.
It has one and a half grams glutamine in it.
But it's a powder.
So you don't have to take a whole scoop.
So if you take a half scoop, you're getting 750 milligrams of glutamine.
It has a really, really good gut healing.
It's a gut healing supplement.
So it's got all these other great supplements that will help heal the gut.
It's a great supplement.
Now, first it has got more active cancer.
Then you go and you're working on trying to heal the gut.
Then you think of something like gastrobed.
That has got less things, but it's got that deglycerized licorice, which is so healing for the gut.
The TR Clear GI also has that licorice.
But if you want to stay away from glutamine altogether,
then you just don't want to risk it.
Then you go with the gastrobed supplement.
But remember, you've got to start with your healing.
You've got to start from the top down.
So are you chewing your food well?
Are you, do you have HCl issues?
That's the, again, the number one digestive problem.
And that's how so many digestive problems start is because of a decrease HCl production.
How does that happen?
Well, it happens because of stress, because of dietary issues,
damaging those cells in the stomach that make HCl.
So you need to support it by adding HCl and digestive enzymes to your diet where you eat.
And then it might be necessary to heal the gut.
Now we'll get, I have multiple videos on HCl and healing the gut
and how HCl deficiency so often leads to Hpilora.
If you look back to Pylora, I have videos on that.
I'm at blog post on that.
So make sure you take a look at that.